bonjour est ce que vous croyez au
bonheur alors qu'ils croient au bonheur
ici jusqu'au bout là bas un bravo bon
bah c'est bon je pars ben moi j'ai très
longtemps j'ai pas cru au bonheur moi
j'y croyais pas le bonheur en fait et ce
que j'ai envie de vous raconter
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est étonnant
mais en fait non seulement je crois au
bonheur mais j'en ai fait mon métier
quand je suis arrivé j'ai rencontré
l'équipe de tadic sereine
ils m'ont dit mais pourquoi le bonheur
est là j'ai eu un temps de pause et je
me suis dit j'étais un peu pris à froid
j'ai dit ben parce que la mort quand
j'avais 3 ans et demi c'est un mes
premiers souvenirs c'est comme une image
que j'ai gardé toute ma vie c'est les
doigts de ma grande tante nénène ya là
le chapelet autour de ces de ses mains
comme ça en rouler comme s'il priait
elle est dans son habit bretonne avec
les grandes manches tout en noir et sont
habillées en velours noir elle a sa
coiffe du pays lorientais plate pas les
bigoudens plate en dentelle et autour il
ya des bretonnes qui prie mon oncle m'a
pris ma amenés dans la cour et m'a
expliqué le paradis je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez
un jour vous allez réaliser vous allez
mourir je trouve que c'est c'est quand
même un fait dans la vie que aussi
important que l'homme qui a marché sur
la lune où les twin towers et les avions
qui rendent des dents et pourtant c'est
rare qu'on se souvienne de ça en fait je
me suis dit en fin de compte on est en
train de m'expliquer quand on est tous
sur un tapis roulant et que gentiment
tous inexorablement on va vers cette
issue fatale ou
on va perdre notre corps notre
conscience on va mourir mais celle
arnaque c'est insupportable c'est une
idée moi que je trouvais c'est immoral
qui a inventé ce truc
g j'ai traîné cette angoisse de la mort
toute mon enfance j'avais des crises
littéralement j'avais des crises de
larmes
moi je voulais pas mourir et puis à 21
ans je suis parti en malaisie je pars en
vacances en malaisie et là j'ai eu une
révélation
en fait cette révélation je me suis dit
mais attendait qu'ils je suis moi qu'est
ce que je veux et puis ce serait quoi
mon bonheur à moi parce que je l'avais
toujours pas trouvé j'avais ses
angoisses et donc je n'ai pas pu
utiliser mon billet retour
mais voilà je n'avais pas d'argent donc
j'ai commencé à travailler suis devenue
serveuse à hong kong
à 21 ans j'avais jamais bu un verre
d'alcool de ma vie je suis bretonne que
c'est pas normal mais c'est comme ça
j'avais bu un verre d'alcool et les
clients mettaient des petits schnaps
allemand et à chaque fois que je passais
je devais prenait 1 prendra schnaps mais
ce qu'ils savent pas les aa les
allemands les hongkongais les chinois
c'est que justement j'ai des globules
breton donc je tiens là et j'ai en fait
parcouru la planète comme ça je suis
parti travailler par exemple au
guatemala je travaillais dans les ruines
mayas au milieu de la jungle avec 70
hommes à creuser la terre dès 7 heures
du matin et on manger des haricots
rouges du matin au soir d'un matin le
matin le midi et le soir
et puis le soir on allait jouer au foot
dans les ruines sur la place royale
j'ai vécu rend aussi au sénégal avec des
bonnes soeurs rail dans le centre de
couture
et puis j'ai parcouru la planète comme
ça un peu partout que ce soit qu'il ya
des pommes en nouvelle-zélande où
travaillent dans un orphelinat en
thaïlande ou bien dans un cinq étoiles
au maroc
j'ai couru comme ça la planète à la
recherche mais c'est quoi
mais en fin de compte quand on court la
planète et convenant à toutes ces vies
mais une sorte d'errance
je me suis aussi perdu en fin de compte
vous rendez compte en voyageant que
votre vision avec votre culture et vos
croyances ou la vie c'est ceci la vie
c'est cela s'écroule aussi
parce qu'il ya autant de visions de la
vérité que d'êtres humains sur terre et
donc je me suis dis bah c'est pas ça je
peux pas faire ça donc je vais prendre
je vais rentrer dans une voix un peu
plus conventionnel et là je suis devenu
acheteuse d'abord dans une pme à
issoudun le centre de la france et ça
c'est une aventure de vivre dans le
centre de la france et je partais
négocier alors au pakistan avec des
directeurs d' usine qui faisait des
gants en coton ou bien je me retrouvais
dans les quelques d'un calcutta dans les
tanneries ou bien en chine
encore en chine est là pour vous faire
flancher dans les négociations ce qu'ils
font c'est que vous allez à table avec
eux ils vous font boire c'était très
drôle
à chaque fois que quelqu'un voulait
boire tout le monde déboires mais ce
qu'ils savaient pas c'est que suis
bretonne
donc je tenais l'alcool traa
et puis j'ai travaillé dans les
multinationales alors là j'avais des
tailleurs j'étais à new york des talons
mots et je négociais des millions $
j'avais une voiture qui était tellement
grande que j'étais obligé de monter dans
le coffre pour aller récupérer les
courses au fond c'était la grande vie et
puis j'ai continué dans d'autres
multinationales je suis parti travailler
amsterdam j'ai travaillé comme
consultante en angleterre et pourtant
c'était toujours pas ça mais ce qui est
dérangeant c'est on sait que c'est pas
ça en tout cas moi je savais que c'était
pas ça mais je savais pas ce que c'était
le sas qu'on devait mettre dedans alors
j'ai tout plaqué et j'ai bu j'ai vu une
petite gorgée d'eau comme ça
j'ai tout plaqué et moi j'avais envie de
vivre en france j'avais envie de vivre à
paris en fait j'avais envie de vivre
dans ma langue j'avais envie de vivre
dans ma gastronomie j'avais envie de
vivre dans ces paysages j'avais envie de
vivre ce climat quoi moi je trouve que
la france un pays magnifique beau et
j'avais envie d'être ici donc j'ai tout
plaqué mais voilà j'avais ni travail ni
revenu donc pas de statut social nous
comment se définit quand on n'a pas de
statut social mais en fait il a fallu
traverser mais peur la peur de manquer
la peur de me planter la peur tout
simplement ne pas être aimé ne pas être
reconnu mais bon on les traverse peu à
peu et pas à pas je me suis puisque je
me pose des questions existentielles sur
la vie bah je vais acheter une caméra
puis je vais aller déposer à des gens
qui semblent savoir et je suis allé
rencontrer des philosophes des
entrepreneurs des résidents des gens qui
sont passés par des des épreuves
difficiles et qui ont ces petites
pépites de bonheur j'ai rencontré des
gens extraordinaires comme je l ai
rencontré un alchimiste au père lachaise
l'interview père lachaise cet alchimiste
pour lui le but de l'alchimie s'est pas
de transformer le plomb en or le but de
l'alchimie c'est le bonheur et donc on
est allé au père lachaise il m'a
décrypter le père lachaise
ou bien j'ai rencontré tellement dur
j'ai tellement de gens extraordinaires
par exemple michel vaujour qui a passé
25 ans en prison que ça et c'est lui qui
s'est échappé de prison en hélicoptère
de la santé je suis sûr qu'ils s'il y en
a qui s'en rappelle ouais michel michel
s'est pris une balle dans la tête et ça
a transformé sa vision sa vision du
monde
j'ai rencontré
alors allez voir l'interview vous
comprendrez pourquoi je sais comme ça ça
paraît bizarre mais j'ai rencontré
magali saby qui est handicapé de
naissance et qui aujourd'hui fait partie
d'une troupe de danse plein de gens
comme ça extraordinaire et puis un jour
il ya une jeune femme qui m'a contacté
qui s'appelle jessica est ensemble on a
créé un laboratoire du bonheur c'est ce
que c'est la mission de ce laboratoire
du bonheur sa semelle api lab c'est de
faire monter la france sur le podium des
pays les plus heureux au monde parce que
c'est possible
non mais je vous vois sceptique mais
c'est possible en fait on part du
principe que en tout cas moi tous toutes
ces perles toutes ces choses que j'ai
appris c'est des petites clés qu'on peut
se sont changés donc en donnant les
outils à chacun de nous de trouver son
propre bonheur ensemble on peut créer
des nouvelles solutions ensemble on peut
se résoudre heroes monde c'est souvent
la peur qui nous empêche de dire mais
oui mais moi j'ai une voix oui moi j'ai
des solutions pour la collectivité
donc on a créé api l'âme aujourd'hui il
ya des milliers de gens en france dans
d'ailleurs même arène qui qui font
partie d'un pis la baie qui font des
événements un peu partout en france
alors comment je sais que c'est ça voyez
ce sale à comment je sais que je suis
heureuse en fait la semaine dernière je
suis allé déjeuner chez mon frère je
sais que ça vous intéresse pas beaucoup
trop mais je raconte est un peu ma vie
j'ai découvert que j'avais dans le coup
là on va regarder la cuisse et les yeux
là
non et bien là j'ai une boule je suis
jamais malade ce que je suis bretonne
puis bon on est à rennes 1 gym sur la
voie et j'ai découvert que j'avais une
moule je me suis dit mais se trouve à
aller voir un médecin et il va me dire
mais mademoiselle vous n'avez plus qu'un
an à vivre
j'ai beau contempler ma mort chaque jour
si on annonçait j'avais carrément à
vivre et si on vous annonçait que vous
n'aviez qu'un an à vivre
qu'est ce que vous feriez de cette année
moi je sais moi je sais exactement ce
que je ferais si j'avais encore un an à
vivre je continuerai à faire exactement
ce que je fais aujourd'hui
non je changerais rien pourquoi je
changerais rien parce qu'en fin de
compte je suis heureuse d'avoir eu si
peur de la mort d'avoir cherché je pense
que ça m'a empêché de m'endormir et du
coup aujourd'hui je me rends compte que
c'est fabuleux parce que même s'il ya eu
des milliards d'hommes avant avant nous
qui ont vécu des milliards qu'ils
vivront après nous ma sensation c'est
que moi je suis le héros du présent et
je suis le héros du nous sommes les
héros du présent aujourd'hui maintenant
donc ce qui m'intéresse c'est là
l'intérêt de cette mort c'est qu'elle
donne la force à ce moment à cette vie
maintenant
et du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait de ce
présent je voulais je voulais partager
avec vous un message que j'ai reçue ce
matin parce que on m'a posé la question
aussi pourquoi aller pourquoi les sur
une scène et parler du bonheur
après tout voilà pourquoi tu nous
racontes ta vie et ce matin j'ai reçu ce
message j'ai donc une chaîne youtube et
les gens peuvent laisser des
commentaires et j'ai reçu ça c'est
johanna l'idiote heureuse l'idiote
nunuche et ricaneuse bercé par bonheur
classique certes mais insupportable mais
un v6 l'heureuse ne comprendra pas et je
vous passe la suite parce que ça devient
très très très grossier et en fait je me
suis dit mais c'est fabuleux
cette personne vient de m'expliquer
pourquoi je monte ici
pourquoi je monte ici parce que je pense
que le bonheur le bonheur c'est
politique
le bonheur de pouvoir dire je suis
heureuse et on peut aussi parler de ça
c'est important
cette personne c'est à dire les gens qui
sont dans la violence eux s'expriment
tout le temps donc je suis ici et je
sais enfin pourquoi pour vous dire il ya
plein de gens qui ont envie aussi
d'aller vers ça le bonheur de le
comprendre
ggd antisèches j'ai lu aussi un article
j'ai découvert un nouveau mot il n'ya
pas longtemps ses entés leschi vous
connaissez en télé chi en télé chi et
c'était un article j'ai traduit de
l'anglais qui dit perfectionnisme
appliquer à soi même c'est désir
d'évoluer et de son concentré sur ses
objectifs les plus élevés et je me suis
dit ça ça c'est mon bonheur à moi c'est
à dire d'apprendre et de progresser et
en même temps dans ce mot en télé chili
a en chine bah oui le bonheur c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas la béatitude c'est
pas tout plat le bonheur pour moi ça
peut aussi être dur et je voudrais finir
avec cette anecdote en fait au début de
l'année
j'ai eu une grosse déception j'étais
triste et je n'arrivais pas à me défaire
de cette tristesse et donc c'était un
matin il pleuvait et j'avais un
parapluie
c'est un parapluie il ya quelques années
je suis allé interviewer luc simonet luc
simonel c'est le président de la ligue
des optimistes du royaume de belgique et
il m'a faire un magnifique parapluie
avec des crises c'est un beau jour de
pluie et donc j'avais mon grand
parapluie de la ligue des optimistes et
j'étais sous la pluie je marchais et le
feu piéton venait de passer au rouge
et là dans les cheveux du monsieur juste
devant moi je remarque des petites
perles de pluie très très beau et je ne
sais pas ce qui me passe par la tête
je fais un pas en avant
et je me retrouve et pour le contre
épaule sous le grand parapluie avec un
homme la cinquantaine je ne connais pas
ce qui est drôle c'est qu'il ya un
moment on ne sait rien dit et puis tout
a un prix me regarde pas forcément je le
regarde
et là je serais même pas le refaire il
dit alors ça c'est la première fois
qu'un truc pareil m'arrive
on a traversé la rue on s'est laissé de
l'autre côté sur le trottoir et ça a
complètement bouleversé ma journée une
journée avec des hasards de la joie ma
tristesse c'était complètement envolées
donc si j'avais peut-être qu'une chose à
vous dire de ce que j'ai pu apprendre en
cinq ans de recherches sur le bonheur
c'est si vous voulez être heureux
commencé par rendre quelqu'un heureux ça
vous rendra immédiatement heureux
multiplier multiplier on va commencer
avec vous un et puis après on fera avec
les autres en france
multipliez multiplier et je pense qu'on
va y monter beaucoup plus vite que prévu
sur ce podium des pays les plus heureux
au monde
merci